hey guys it's Monday morning I just came
back from running time for a shower and
a week
[Music]
to speak out can project it's called
silent game so it's like the traditional
silent game way where you get the
pattern of the sounds and we have to
beat them after 2017 in to just correct
their force you win
[Music]
going for everything with friends
[Music]
[Music]
I feel phone feedback is always wearing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I've been working on Simon game since
the beginning of this week this week I
did two comments and I started this
project that at the end of the last week
introducing the basic UI but the basic
UI I mean it's responsive right now
however it hates much what much more
work to be ready to go so far I've
implemented there by the user stories
let me show you that I presented with
problem a series of button presses this
is the random series random array each
time I hit restart there's a new random
serious each time it starts from step
one and if I press the button correctly
I have one new sound added to repeat
from this array
this will continue until 20 steps and
after the twentieth step the game is
over and the user Wang so the first is
our story is implemented the next one is
each time I include a series of button
presses correctly I see the same series
of button process with the an additional
step this is also implemented I hear a
sound that corresponds to each button
whenever I had it for the computer he
hits okay so this user story is also
implemented that the sons are hurt if I
press the wrong button
I'm notified and also and the series of
patterns is repeated let me make mistake
so it's four four one one so I will do 2
2 1 1 so here there was goopes listen
again and the pattern is repeated so the
user story is implemented I can see how
many steps are in the current series of
button presses is exactly here at the
top right now
if I want to restart I can hit Ibaka to
do so and the game will wear on return
to a single stack yep it works I can
play this trick mode where everybody
make mistake so then it will be
restarted so let me play in strict mode
so I have to press for because it was
first step without any mistake four two
four two four and let's make a mistake
so four two one
and as you see his notification that I
made a mistake but I come back directly
to the first step and I have to start
the game from the top and the last user
story
I can win the game by getting a series
of 20 steps correct and notified of my
victory dang then the game starts over 3
1 1 4 and the less sound be careful look
here what will happen
[Music]
so I move notified and the game starts
over from the first step so it's
implemented to sum up all of the user
stories are implemented and there's the
basic UI which is also responsive
however it doesn't look well yet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just recorded myself for the signing
name I'm going to listen to it right now
I deployed the project to the server
time for bait
[Music]
[Music]
it's Thursday morning and I still
haven't left much to my design I've just
answered code newbies questions on
Twitter this week if you are learning to
code and haven't heard about them it's
really great community so you should
check them out
okay so we were expired but definitely
there's a problem sometimes with the
sound so I would have to polish it with
it
website again problem of the sounds and
poverty segments Internet Explorer works
it's Thursday evening and I've been
fighting with mobile and sounds and
animations on mobile for the Holi means
that's it for today that's it and I will
come back to this tomorrow maybe I will
find the solutions mobile animations
mobile sounds I hate you it's Friday
morning and this is my app after the
whole week though so the app is working
right now so you can play it it's fully
responsive
the problem that I have right now is
looking for some solution for audio
because it's not working properly on
mobile devices this is the problem that
game developers also have is I've
noticed so it may be tough but keep your
fingers crossed I hope I find some
solution and solve this problem it's
Friday evening I finally did it
your disorders change dynamically as a
result I can play it on mobile devices
which is great because I don't need each
time the audio to be triggered by a user
because it's still one and the same
audio that's it the week is over I
introduced all of the user stories from
silent game I tested it and improved its
you acts and it's life right now the
main problem was html5 audio on mobile
browsers the plans for the next week I'm
going to revise all of my previous
projects from free cope calm breath
design some of them especially the
portfolio get to 500 points on brownies
in free code camp community and play my
first front-end certificates at the end
of the first week of blogging it was
very fun and motivating so I will
continue doing it it's really great so
keep on hacking see you next week
[Music]